The Writers Guild of America reportedly
walking away from the negotiation table
without a deal tonight.
Their contract expires
at midnight Pacific Time.
And at this moment, Hollywood is bracing
for a strike if it happens.
Who will entertain us?
Will it be a I?
Or will we have to rely on Harry Enten?
Here it is.
Here's what that would look like.
Yes. I have one question for you.
Obviously,
you're the comedian of the evening,
but if you were not, in fact,
the comedian of the evening,
would you actually be watching this event?
You're the user I guy, you know?
Yeah, I know. Exactly.
And I know
because what's going up against Monday
Night Football is and I'll DVR
and check back on it later.
That's a great question.
I have no idea what I'm doing here.
So, you know,
they call this the nerd prom.
I have to ask how does this compare
to your actual prom back in the day?
Well, actually,
there is no difference between this prom.
My actual prom.
I don't have a date to either one.
Well,
I was a nerd, so this feels right to me.
Your accent makes my accent
look so crummy by comparison.
And people always say,
I have this thick New York accent,
but nothing compared to your accent.
Wow. Who could make this sound? Who?
I don't think anyone could make it up.
High, that is.
How much fun did you have?
I have to be honest,
I was nervous going into it.
And the reason you'd never
you never had you going to the White House
Correspondents Dinner?
I had once attended
I had worked on, you know, coverage.
But feedback from the studio. Right.
Got on the red carpet,
not on the red carpet.
And I think you know, one of the things
that people take for granted,
perhaps from watching television
is they don't realize
there are certain people
who have some skills
and other people who have other skills.
And so the idea that I would hold
a microphone up to somebody
and ask them questions is not something
I've really ever done before.
Right. I'm not a field reporter.
I'm usually in the safe
confines of the studio
where someone like you
is asking me questions
and I'm giving the response
instead of the other way around.
And it's like, oh, my God,
am I going to do something wrong?
And so
perhaps there was some nervous energy
that was coming out during that clip,
but it seemed it seemed to work.
I feel like you have a perfect question.
Sure. Roy Wood, Junior.
Right off the front.
Right off the bat.
He hesitated.
Oh, how should I know? That was great.
I'm hosting that.
Also, I probably wouldn't be watching
watch a football.
So I feel like
I feel like you nailed it, man.
Well, thank you. That's very, very.
I will endorse you to go out and
do it again next year if you so choose.
If that means anything to anyone.
Let's get him back out there.
I'm hoping you also have.
Yeah, if we have Oscar coverage,
I'm hoping that maybe.
There we go. Here.
What else do you want to translate?
Like, let's just, you know, maybe that's
what is going on.
Met Gala. That's a good one.
Yeah, you bet. You had to run out.
That is good.
I just like also that, you know, most,
you know, television journalists go up
and they interview people in the field,
you know, less about different things,
the gas prices, the milk prices.
And you start at the White House
Correspondents Dinner, red carpet.
That's like that's the starting point
for interviewing people.
No pressure. Yeah, no.
No pressure.
I sort of leaked ahead.
But, you know, it's interesting to me also
was the types of celebrities
that where they are, right?
So, you know, there were a lot of people
who were well known
in the 1990s of the early 2000
that actually played very well for me
because that's all of my pop culture
reference.
Perfect.
So shall we see a little bit
more of you. Yeah.
Let's let's let's talk these
Look there.
MATTINGLY I wonder if he'll tell us tales
from his baseball days.
You know what
I would love to see do this event.
Chris Rock.
Oh, that wasn't here at the.
Okay,
You said it, not me.
Very hard of myself.
Do you suggest that he gets for dinner
if he's looking for something interesting
to eat in Bentonville, Arkansas?
Well, of course, you know,
the barbecue can't be beat there.
You stand, then you stand.
Now, when the heck do you ever sit down?
I'll start on this
and it's sort of a foodie paradise there.
So you'll find a lot of different options
and some incredible tacos.
Mexican food.
How long did that conversation
with Asa Hutchinson go on?
You know, I got to say, the former
governor was very kind and at what it was,
as my friend
Neil Payne moved to Bentonville, Arkansas.
So he's actually neighbors
with Asa Hutchinson.
So I was legitimately ask him a question.
I was looking out for my buddy Neil.
I was like, where can Neal
get a good bite to eat in Bentonville?
Arkansas.
So, you know, it wasn't just about me.
It was also about my friends.
And I'm sure I've learned in terms
of tomorrow's news.
How many relationships will
you have to repair now that Harry has done
this to various,
you know, like peppered people on?
I mean, it's actually good training
and a good reminder for me on Capitol
Hill, like how I can get some attention
from Senators like I can use your strategy
like the red carpet strategy in the halls
of the Dirksen Office Building.
But that was just waving
and jumping that Harry.
Well, I mean, we'll try it.
We'll see if it works.
You know, everyone has their own strategy,
much more echoey in that building
than on that card. I think Senator
Bernie Sanders would love that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He would love that.
He would respond Yeah.
I think the question would be,
who has the best accent?
Me, Fran Drescher or Bernie Sanders?
All right. All right. Well,
we won't answer that because then
I would have to repair that relationship.
Yeah, you're right.
So what was your favorite moment?
I think if we have some sound of it,
there was a moment
with someone from the 1990 show wings,
which was very big for me.
I don't know if we have the sound.
Do we have that sound?
We, we do.
Let's listen to what
Harry. Harry, I'm Tim.
Yeah, I know you because I watch the show.
Wings. Wings
is one of my favorite shows of all time.
You must have been four years
old, but. Great. I'm glad you watched it.
I was on an episode of Wings.
Were you really?
Yeah.
I played this
tall girl at a single stance,
and I started crying because I'm too tall
and no one wants to dance with me.
You're not too tall for me.
I'll never take all three of us
wear heels.
Actually, that's the that's
the little known secret of this team.
Whatever you want
to wear is all right by me.
Can you believe they allow me to do this?
No, we can't, actually.
Oh, that was great.
That was really fun.
Well, it was a pleasure being there.
And although I was nervous to start out
with, it's
great to expand my wings and prove that
I can be someplace besides the studio.
Yeah, you spread your wings,
and you obviously hooked up
with your all time wings.
That's why I'm growing.
I love the show
Wings. That theme song is fantastic.
And I've even flown in the plane that is
featured in the opening credits of Wings.
So it all came together.
Fun fact. That's fun.
All right.
All right. Thank you very much for that.